Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Marley was dead to begin with. There is no doubt whatever about that. The register of his burial was signed by the clergyman, the clerk, the undertaker and the chief mourner. Scrooge signed it. And Scrooge's name was good upon change for anything he chose to put his hand to.
Old Marley was as dead as a doornail well happy christmas everybody um that was dominic of course um reading the opening to a christmas carol and dominic here we are just before christmas professional quality and what could what could be more festive than to actually be out and about in the streets of this great capital of ours so i stand here and I see a sign that says, Motorcyclists, please do not start your engines. We're standing in what, untutored eyes, Tom, would seem like a sort of just a deserted yard.
But you're going to explain why you dragged me from my... All the way from the Cotswolds, your hobbit hole in the Cotswolds, all the way down into the very heart of London. And I have to say that you are looking absolutely full of festive fare. My face like thunder as I walked into the coffee shop before
the recording started. As you were walking here, ragamuffins were knocking your top hat off with snowballs. They could tell the Scrooge-like expression on your face full of christmas cheer there's nothing i like more than being summoned down to london by tom holland uh with a pandemic raging exactly well we so we're in we're in a place called newman court which is just off cornhill and cornhill is one of the main roads in the city of London. It leads from the Bank of England up towards Leadenhall Market but the reason we're here is that insofar
as we can tell Newman Court is the likeliest place for Scrooge's counting house. So Scrooge obviously the central character in A Christmasmas carol the kind of definitive canonical christmas text probably the most adapted christmas definitely well i mean probably the most the most adapted story in english maybe in the world yeah apart from the nativity itself yeah apart from that yes another word fiction so written in published in december 1843 by charles dickens the same the same year apparently as, as Christmas cards were first sent. Is that right? So, yeah, it's a great year for the Victorian Christmas. Very big year. Well, of course, Christmas has sort of been in the ether a little bit
for the Victorians for a few years before Christmas Carol comes out. You know, the amazing thing, actually, Tom, you know how old Dickens, obviously, you do know how old he was when he... Remind me. 31. Yeah. 31, and he'd already written six books. Well, I mean, I think the thing about Dickens, so when he's writing this, as you say, he's a young man. I mean, when you read about how he came to write Christmas Carol, what impresses you, as almost every detail of Dickens always does,
is the unbelievable sense of energy. Yeah. I mean, kind of terrifying terrifying almost demonic level of energy because as he it took him six six weeks to write christmas carol as he wrote it he would kind of laugh and cry and gurn and prance around the room whenever there was any but he's also doing these walks at night isn't he was walking 15 20 miles so he walks around london and then he relaxes by going for 50 miles across the city. He's sort of extraordinary.
But he does it partly because he needs money. So he's written, he's had some quite big name books. So Pickwick Papers, Oliver Twist, Nicholas Nickleby. But his most recent book, Martin Charlesowitz, has been a bit of a failure. His wife, I think, is expecting another baby. His publishers have basically told him they're nagging him yeah they've told him they're going to pay him less unless he basically improves and ups his game so obviously Christmas makes sense because he knows in this kind of domesticated Victorian
world middle-class world there are lots of people who are interested in Christmas as a kind of family holiday and are interested in kind of reviving some of the traditions that have been lost because that's a lot of what a Christmas character it's inventing and reviving Christmas traditions and Christmas seems to be incredibly important to Dickens so right from the beginning he's sketches by Boss his very first work there's a whole you know one of the sketches is of Christmas and right you know um the mystery of Edwin Drood which is his last unfinished novel. There's a kind of a murder that takes place
actually on Christmas. So it's a theme that runs right the way through. And I guess that, you know, I mean, people always, when they talk about Dickens' psychology, they always go back
to the trauma. The blacking factory. The blacking, you know, he gets sent to a blacking factory. His father goes to a debtor's prison. The sense in which, beyond the, you you know the comforts of a middle-class household yeah well ignorance and want who are the two children who um the ghost
of christmas future shows to um well the sort of coziness tom i think of dickens and of christmas depend upon the darkness absolutely you know yeah the fire is burning in the grates and stuff but outside the the wind is howling the snow is coming down or whatever you need both yeah for the sort of Christmas stories to really work yeah and I think that um a Christmas Carol just I mean why is it so successful I think I mean it it kind of partly does echo the kind of the rhythms of the original christmas story so you have three visitors rather like you know the three kings um scrooge goes to visit tiny tim the little little child rather like the the shepherds and the three kings go to visit the baby jesus so it it kind of brilliantly riffs on that without
making it too obvious but i think it is also fairytale quality too though absolute fairytale quality but it that there is it is also rooted in an absolute sense of how brutal life can be for the poor so um the two two um episodes in dickens's life just before he writes it that might have um influenced him one is he he's gone to america in 1842 so the year before he writes yeah martin chuzzlewit and he goes to this penitentiary in pittsburgh yes he goes into a cell and he writes to his friend uh john forster and he says i went into the cell and i was struck by the terrifying thought what if the convict in this cell is visited by ghosts you know that's part of the punishment yeah and that's obviously a kind of idea that's playing with him and the other is that he goes to a ragged school that's been set up in saffron hill which is um it's uh
um kind of by home and viaduct very you know yes so that's basically a school for urchins isn't it yeah but but it was absolute slum in this time it's where fagans um uh hangs out with all the the pickpockets in all of it also tom scrooge so scrooge is such an interesting figure because there's a bit of dickens in him dickens is very ambitious dickens is very concerned about money dickens is terrified of being lonely and abandoned obviously he's lost he lost his father for a time as a boy and some sort of dickens biographers have said there's a bit of the portrait of scrooge is the two sides that dickens sees in his own character there's the sort of hard the guy who's all about work and money squeezing retching gasping scraping clutching covetous old sinner yes exactly and then there's the sort of open-handed
oh go and get a turkey i love christmas and those those are the two sides of dickens's own persona that he's sort of exploring here anyway let's talk about the place so dickens so scrooge's counting house is pretty much it's pretty much the first location i think we we encounter isn't it in the book as far as i remember my my memory of christmas carol is slightly colored by the muppet christmas carol which i'm sure which is the one i'm most sure we'll come to how do we know where where the address of the counting house where it opens where um scrooge and his clerk bob cratchit are working on Christmas Eve. I mean, we're not given a precise address, but we're given various clues.
So we are told that nearby there is the ancient tower of a church whose gruff old bell was always peeping slyly down at Scrooge out of a Gothic window in the wall. And this church, we're told, becomes invisible and struck the hours and quarters in the clouds with tremulous vibrations afterwards as if its teeth were chattering in its frozen head up there. So the key detail there is it's a Gothic window. There are two or three churches in the city of London with Gothic windows. Most of them obviously got incinerated in the Great Fire. One of the churches is on cornhill st michael's cornhill okay um and that's a key detail because um you'll remember that bob cratchit yeah the clerk he goes he asks scrooge could he have you know can he have christmas day off and scrooge
is kind of very cross about that but then says yes okay you can um and we're told that when the clerk uh bob cratchit um leaves scrooge's office he goes out with the long ends of his white comforter so his um i guess that's his scarf really dangling below his waist for he boasted no great coat he went down a slide on cornhill at the end of a lane of boys 20 times in honour of it being Christmas Eve and then ran home to Camden Town as hard as he could pelt to play at Blind Man's Bar.
That's a hell of a run. It is. That's quite a run. It's two or three miles. But he's obviously full of energy from having sat shivering. He's Kermit the Frog in the Muppet version.
Exactly. So you don't know at this stage, by the way, interestingly, that he's Bob Cratchit. No, that comes later. Yeah, that comes later. So if you put those details together, you've got the church, you've got the fact that Bob Cratchit goes out from the office
and he slides up and down Cornhill. Yeah. The likelihood is, you know, from the description, that it is this place here, which is a narrow, dark passageway coming off Cornhill. And as you say now, I mean, it's a very unromantic spot. Yes, there's some good air conditioning units but there's a kind of proper dickensian blackness to some of the brick work there is so just just for some of our overseas listeners we should say exactly where we are
because we're in the heart of the city of london which is not the london that most visitors see so the old city of london there's some things that visitors they might see some balls but generally people come they see the west end yeah they see this is this is not that this is the financial district now and it's the heart i mean it's the oldest center of london so we're actually standing on what was the forum in in the roman city that's a good fact i didn't know that and corn hill uh obviously it's a hill on which they saw corn. Yeah, they saw corn, right. And it runs parallel to Threadneedle Street, where tailors lived and where the Bank of England is. And there are quite a few of these sort of courts and alleys, aren't there? You never notice them when you're rushing past. They're often quite old, sort of Victorian.
There would have been all sorts of counting houses, offices. There would have been kind of rookeries and slums across the city of London. Yeah, I think fewer, fewer rookeries and slums here in the city. Maybe. Because it's, you know, it is a place as it always has been for finance and banks and counting houses and money. But it would have been much, I would say, less like the London of today and more like going to some great, huge, you know, Chinese city or something where rich and poor jumbled up together in this sort of chaos of people.
I mean, although already you're starting to get the way in which it's the rich bankers. So it's Scrooge who lives actually in the centre, as we'll find out. And Bob lives further out. Bob Cratchit lives further out. So he's already, I mean, he's having to walk. That's true. He's having to commute. But that said, the streets are still littered with urchins with beggars i mean we have lots of
references to that yes yeah absolutely which is obviously not the case now because we're here on a working day admittedly in the middle of a pandemic but the place is practically deserted in many ways yeah yeah but the back the backdrop is absolutely of wealth for those who have it. It's domestically centred. It's behind the doors of grand houses. And then out on the streets, there's poverty and suffering and want. Absolutely. All right. Well, shall we move on to our next location, Tom? Right. So Bob Cratchit, he's gone home to Camden. Yeah.
And Scrooge, we're told, goes out for a rather grim and unhappy meal. And I think that we should go next to the place where, the most likely place where he had this meal. For a grim and unhappy meal. For a grim and unhappy meal. I look forward to it. So, Dominic, we've come to Bengal Court, which is another of these kind of amazing side alleys. It's a lovely kind of warren, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely warren. It's a little warren of kind of alleys and courts. Of Cornhill.
So if you're walking down Cornhill and you didn't go down this kind of warren of streets, you have no idea they were here. But the reason we've come here is we're following're following scrooge who has left his counting house uh and in christmas carol we're told that he took his melancholy dinner in his usual melancholy tavern and having read all the newspapers and beguiled the rest of the evening with his banker's book so he knows how to party went home to bed very soundbroke uh that's that's notbrook at all. So there are a couple of candidates, aren't there? There are a couple of pins we've walked past. There was Simpsons.
There was an old Jamaica or something like that. Jamaica. But this one, I think, is... The George and the Vulture. Yes. And they have a bust, don't they? Which we are standing beside. Yes.
Of the great man. And actually... That's Dickens, not Scrooge, by the way. I feel like a ragamuffin pressing my nose to the window and gazing because it is a very very dickensian scene there are kind of tables laid well it's all laid for christmas glasses for christmas and this bust of dickens gazing out over it um and apparently this is where um every year just before christmas members of the dickens family congregate in a room.
Even now. Yes, in a room upstairs to toast Dickens himself. So, of course, there is a kind of mood of Dickensian jollity here. But for Scrooge, this is all about gloom and misery. He's obviously having kind of a miserable meal, doesn't have any friends. It's Christmas Eve. Yes. And then he goes home.
And again, we don't know. Dickens doesn't tell us where his home is. But again, presumably it's off Cornhill because all the action. It's down one of these courts, isn't it? And he lived in chambers which had once belonged to his deceased partner. There are gloomy suite of rooms and a luring pile of building up a yard where it had so little business to be, though one could scarcely help fancy it must have run there
when it was a young house, playing at hide-and-seek with other houses and forgotten the way out again. Exactly. So we know because in due course he will order a turkey from Leadenhall Market, which is just around the corner. His counting house is here. His likely place of supper is here. So I think the likeliest candidate is a place called white lion court which again is off corn hill uh has an 18th century house and the description you just read it
said you know it's an old house right so we we don't know it's entirely fictional but let's go there because that is and look at the door on which perhaps marley's face appears as Scrooge goes up to the door on Christmas Eve. And can we talk while we're doing that, Tom? Do you think that's reasonable? I think we should talk about Scrooge. Okay, let's do that. Because what strikes me about Scrooge is that he's obviously a sort of repulsive
and grasping and greedy figure, but he's sad, isn't he? Even from the beginning, he's sad having his dinner on his own. Well, there's the awful, and we're slightly jumping the gun here but when the ghost of christmas past comes and shows him um his memories the very sad description of him um at his school well everyone's gone home of course he's alone at his desk yeah with no friends the loneliness is a huge
part of the story i think i think that's one reason why it appeals. Because there's a bit of Scrooge. There's a bit of Scrooge in all of us. That sort of deliberately cynical, miserable, because we feel lonely or left out or whatever. Do you not think? Yes, Dominic. Well, I mean... I'm thinking of you, actually, Tom. I'm thinking of you.
I'm just trying to be nice to you. As you say, Dominic, there's a little bit of Scrooge in all of us anyway so we're now we've come back out we've come back out from the Warren of Raisin
we're going past beneath St. Michael's Cornhill with the Gothic window it is indeed a very high tower so this is the church right it's Christopher Wren Church
unusually for a Wren Church it has these Gothic windows so it's not a Wren Church like you know that you would traditionally expect not a classic and church that you would traditionally expect. No, not a classic. And we're back on Corn Hill.
Some nice drilling in the background. We're walking up Corn Hill from the Bank of England towards what is the highest point in the whole city of London. But you'd barely know it. So it's one of the three hills of London. It's not really a hill, is it? I mean, it's barely an incline. Tower Hill, Ludgate Hill, on which St. Paul stands, and this, Corn Hill.
With these colossal kind of financial towers now overshadowing it. So the language of money, I mean, it absolutely dominates, obviously, Christmas Carol. It's all about the Bank of england exchange bills of exchange ledgers all that kind of stuff and as we as we walk up to um towards leadenhall towering over us are the heirs of well they are i mean there's like scrooges counting house there's the sort of what's that is that the that the Lloyd's building? Yeah, the Lloyd's building is further down. The Lloyd's building, further along. The cheese grater.
We've got the gherkin behind that. If you ever watch those fantastic kind of recolourised, you know, sort of newsreel and things, kind of early film visions of Edwardian London or early 20th century London, the demographic mix is very different from how it is today it's a lot older it's a lot more socially variegated than you know when we walk around these streets yeah but there's only one kind of people here yeah although I mean we're going to be doing uh an episode aren't we in the new year on 1922 we are as the year in which modernity is born um and that's the year in which the wasteland is is published. And Elliot gives this kind of terrifying description of...
The people sweeping across the... Yeah, the people crossing London Bridge, the dead. I had not thought death had undone so many. Yes. Anyway, so we have come to one of the many candidates for where Scrooge's house might have been. Oh, this looks perfect, Tom. This genuinely looks absolutely perfect. So it's White Lion Court, and there's an old house.
It looks rather handsome now. It's painted in a bright kind of purple. There are a couple of lions stuck outside. So very much cheerier than it might have been if this had been Scrooge's house. But it could once have looked fantastically dreary. You could make it look fantastically dreary, couldn't you? Absolutely. So what is it, probably Georgian house, judging by the sort of windows?
Yeah, so it's an 18th century house. But I guess you could imagine a door knocker on those doors and it kind of warping. So tell us about the door knocker, Tom. So Scrooge comes up to it, knocks on it, sees Marley's face. Marley is his partner who's died. And he, humbug, humbug, goes upstairs and has a festive... This is the first hint isn't there of the supernatural that and our producer was saying to us as we were walking over that um that's one of the elements
that makes this such a great story it's not just the lesson it's not just the sentiment but it's also that it's quite scary and particularly it's interesting because now it's often thought of as quite a children's story so you can buy it as a puffin children's classic and obviously thanks to the muppets it's become a kind of family you know a sort of family and it's kind of stages pantomimes and things yeah but not at the time that it's not a children's story at all at the time is it i mean dickens is writing for adults absolutely so so so famously So famously, Scrooge retires for the night and he hears a clanking and a dragging. Yeah. And into his room walks the ghost of Jacob Marley.
And Jacob Marley is dragging behind him ledger books and chains and all the appurtenances of his long career as a banker and perhaps the most chilling detail of all he has a cloth wrapped around um his underneath his jaw and over his head and at one point he removes it and his jaw drops off that's right like rob spear that's what happens at rob spear so all the obviously all the muscles and everything that are holding the jaw have have frayed away while he's been in the grave so that's that's that's very frightening and marley says i'm going to be sending you three ghosts basically to pep you up yeah so marley teach you the meaning of christmas he's john the baptist here isn't he he's not the messenger himself but he's the sort of well he's a messenger isn't he he's the angel announcing the yes the ghosts that are going to come um
but i mean so dickens's attitudes to ghosts i mean he does i think see them as i mean he has he's a 19th century man he's skeptical about them he he you know ostensibly doesn't believe in them but you can see from the anecdote of him being terrified in in the pittsburgh and he wrote the century which is one of the great ghost stories ever yeah brilliant and actually the 70s TV adaptation with Denholm Elliot, absolutely superb. So Dickens is, like all Victorians, fascinated by death, by memory,
by the spiritual, all those kinds of things. And I think that one of the things about living through the pandemic at the moment is it does take us back to the kind of world in which death was a constant present yeah in life uh and that one of the reasons why christmas is so important to dickens is precisely that the streets are stalked by pestilence and um yes that's that thing about the darkness and the cozy right yeah you need that the darkness makes the bright seem all the brighter. Yeah. So Marley retires and Scrooge is left alone. Marley says, you don't believe in me, do you?
And Scrooge says, I don't believe you at all. You may be an undigested bit of beef, a blot of mustard, a crumb of cheese, a fragment of an underdone potato. There's more of gravy than of grave about you, whatever you are. There's more gravy than of grave. That's such a great line. But that's kind of brilliant, me, Dickkenzi and having his cake and eating it you know doubting that it exists and yet it's kind of horrible yeah and terrifying at the same time so marley withdraws and then these three ghosts yes come um so the ghost of christmas past
first of all yeah so we're digging into scrooge's own past here aren't we so it starts i think with that tremendous scene that you mentioned of scrooge he's basically a boarding school everybody else has gone home for the holidays he is on his own this sort of a solitary child neglected by his friends he's left there still and that you see that's the thing that when i said i know you thought it was hilarious when i said there's a bit of scrooge and all that's rather like richard nixon um but well richard nixon's not unlike scrooge actually uh but that sort of thing of being the one child who's left behind i mean there are very few listeners who went empathized with that some you know weren't the last we picked up after the party or whatever and and that's that's very dickens yeah that
taking somebody boys into the blacking factory yeah to their childhood roots that's that's very Dickens. Yeah. Taking somebody boys into the blacking factory to their childhood roots. That's where it all went wrong. You know, the mean spiritedness of your nature is rooted in sadness and solitariness and all those things. Yeah. And then the ghost of Christmas past takes us through Scrooge's memories. And there is a description of an absolutely kind of classic Dickensian Christmas knees up yeah um Mr Fezziwig Fezziwig or Fozziwig as he is in the Muppets version he's Fozzibear um and it's uh it's a wonderful um there's a kind of wonderful illustration
taking somebody boys into the blacking factory yeah to their childhood roots that's that's very Dickens. Yeah. Taking somebody boys into the blacking factory to their childhood roots. That's where it all went wrong. You know, the mean spiritedness of your nature is rooted in sadness and solitariness and all those things. Yeah. And then the ghost of Christmas past takes us through Scrooge's memories. And there is a description of an absolutely kind of classic Dickensian Christmas knees up yeah um Mr Fezziwig Fezziwig or Fozziwig as he is in the Muppets version he's Fozzibear   and it's uh it's a wonderful um there's a kind of wonderful illustration
um by John Leach who did the early illustrations of Mr fezwig dancing it's a welsh wig mr fezwig i don't know what a welsh wig yes and they strike up um sir roger de coverley which was an english dance right named after a character in the spectator and spectator yeah no i i think the early 18th century spectator rather than the uh boris johnson edited spectator um but i've always i've always wondered, you know, I felt that that's a bit that's been missing from my Christmas. You like to do a bit more dancing? I'd like to do Sir Roger de Covelly.
um by John Leach who did the early illustrations of Mr fezwig dancing it's a welsh wig mr fezwig i don't know what a welsh wig yes and they strike up um sir roger de coverley which was an english dance right named after a character in the spectator and spectator yeah no i i think the early 18th century spectator rather than the uh boris johnson edited spectator   but i've always i've always wondered, you know, I felt that that's a bit that's been missing from my Christmas. You like to do a bit more dancing? I'd like to do Sir Roger de Covelly.
I have no idea what it is. I'm not going to go with you now. Any of the listeners out there have any idea what Sir Roger de Covelly sounds like, you know, let us know. I'd love to hear it. Yes, maybe they can let us know on the Discord chat if they're members of the Rest Is History Club.
An ideal Christmas present, and it is not too late to go to restishist hear it. Yes. Maybe they can let us know on the Discord chat. If you're a member of the Restless History Club, an ideal Christmas present, and it is not too late to go to restlesshistorypod.com. Yes, if you want to come in out of the darkness and the cold into our... That's brilliant promotional work. I thought that was completely seamless. Very Scrooge-like. Well, I've got my ledgers with me. So, yes.
So basically, Scrooge has shown the process by which this this young boy who um who you know he might have married he might have had a family but he decides not to because he chooses to marry his ledger book that's right because his sort of his sweetheart abandons him is she called bella yes yeah she she says you care about money more than me and he says humbug yeah exactly and he's absolutely right so the ghost of christmas um the past goes scrooge wakes up he's well he's a bit discombobulated yeah but still not entirely convinced and then the ghost of christmas present arrives and the ghost of christmas present is absolutely fantastic because he appears he's like a feast in human form he does and he's he he's a kind of giant colossal bearded man but he has a great throne
which consists entirely of festive food so turkeys geese game poultry brawn great joints of meat sucking pigs long wreaths of sausages mince pies plum puddings barrels of oysters red hot chestnuts cherry-cheeked apples juicy oranges luscious pears immense 12th cakes and seething bowls of punch that made the chamber dim with their delicious steam my my christmas dinner that's exactly how i imagine the sanbrook household exactly over christmas yeah absolutely you with a great horn of plenty toasting ragamuffins exactly turkeys out left right and center to the poor. Throwing shillings to urchins.
Exactly. That's how I imagine it. Anyway, so the Ghost of Christmas Present then shows Scrooge what's going on. Well, they go to the market, don't they? Isn't that the first thing where people are kind of all... They're basically doing their Christmas shopping. Yeah, and they're all happy. And everyone in Dickens loves doing Christmas shopping.
Yeah, it's very, very unlike the reality. So wholly implausible and fictional. Yeah. They all absolutely adore it. The sort of stressed people, like, juggling wrapping paper, desperately fighting for the last pigs in blankets and Tesco. Yes. And then he is shown his nephew, who we should have mentioned earlier,
had come in. So Fred has previously said, why don't you come and join us for Christmas? And Scrooge has said, bar humbug. Yeah, he has said bar humbug. So Scrooge has shown them all kind of saying what a miserable old stick Scrooge is. Well, they play some sort of game, don't they, where they have to guess who he is. I'm a sort of animal. Yes, a kind of miserable old terrifying creature, monster.
And it's Scrooge, and Scrooge's gut is when he finds out that they're laughing at him behind his back and then they are taken to camden and to bob cratchit's house where all the various cratchit children are feasting on a goose which is a very small goose and there's a very small christmas pudding but because they have the spirit of christmas they're happy never was such a goose bob said he didn't believe there ever was such a goose cooked it's tenderness and flavor size and cheapness with the themes of universal admiration and is there a particular child dominic who perhaps you've made play with in a advert for beer on our podcast see the producers this time finds this absolutely hilarious because he wrote it he wrote it he wrote it
这就是斯克鲁奇，斯克鲁奇内心触动是在他发现别人背地里笑话他之后，然后他们被带到了卡姆登和鲍勃·克拉奇特的家里，在那里，克拉奇特家的各种孩子们正在大嚼一只鹅，那是一只非常小的鹅，还有一个非常小的圣诞布丁，但因为他们有圣诞精神，所以他们很快乐，从来没有过这样一只鹅，鲍勃说他不相信曾经有过这样一只鹅被煮过，它的嫩度、风味、大小和便宜是人们普遍赞美的对象，多米尼克，有没有哪个特定的孩子，也许你在我们播客的啤酒广告里和他一起演过戏，这回制片人们觉得这绝对太搞笑了，因为这是他写的，这是他写的，这是他写的
Tiny Tom I will perhaps save a glass of beer 52 I hope they pay us extra for this in episode advertising for Tiny Tom yeah so
小汤姆，我或许会留一杯啤酒，52，我希望他们在插播小汤姆广告的这集里能给我们多付点工钱，是啊，所以
Tiny Tim so Tiny Tim now Tiny Tim is kind of Little Nell isn't he really so Little Nell was the character in the old Curiosity Shop
小蒂姆，所以小蒂姆，现在小蒂姆有点像小耐尔，不是吗？真的，所以小耐尔是《老古玩店》里的角色
who had famously I hesitate to spoil it for people but she dies and there had been universal kind of weeping and waiting all those listeners who are just just three quarters of the way through the old curiosity how many such listeners do you think there are i'm sure there are lots actually ruined people in america had famously kind of you know being at the quayside waiting for the next heart of stone not to laugh. But Tiny Tim is kind of little Nell. He's a sentimental martyr figure with his crutches
她有着著名的——我犹豫要不要给人们剧透，但她死了——而且曾有过普遍的哭泣和等待，所有那些刚好读到《老古玩店》四分之三的听众，你们觉得有多少这样的听众？我确信其实有很多，美国那些心碎的人们曾出名地在码头边等待下一颗冷酷的心不要笑。但小蒂姆有点像小耐尔。他是一个带着拐杖的感伤烈士形象
carried on Bob Cratchit's back. Bob is incredibly long-suffering and will run with Tiny Tim and Tiny Tim can do no wrong. And he toasts Scrooge. He does. To Mr. Scrooge who made it possible. And his wife, who's Miss Piggy in the Muppet version says, Scrooge, if he was To Mr. Scrooge who made it possible. And his wife, who's Miss Piggy, in the Muppet version, says, Scrooge, if he was here, I would
被扛在鲍勃·克拉奇特的背上。鲍勃极其忍辱负重，会陪着小蒂姆奔跑，小蒂姆做什么都是对的。他向斯克鲁奇祝酒。他确实这么做了。为了让这一切成为可能的可敬的斯克鲁奇先生。而他的妻子——在布偶版里是猪小姐——说，斯克鲁奇，如果他为了让这一切成为可能的可敬的斯克鲁奇先生。而他的妻子，在布偶版里是猪小姐，说，斯克鲁奇，如果他在这里，我会
give him that box of his ears or whatever. And, um... But Bob is so... Bob is such a sort of fine fellow. But he won't hear a word against Scrooge. Even if Scrooge treats him like dirt. And Tiny Tim is obviously a chip off the old block, because he has his famous toast,
揪他的耳朵或者别的什么。而且，嗯……但鲍勃是如此……鲍勃是一个如此好的人。但他不愿听到半句反对斯克鲁奇的话。哪怕斯克鲁奇像对待垃圾一样对待他。而小蒂姆显然有其父之风，因为他有他那句著名的祝酒词，
God bless us all, everyone. God bless us everyone, yes. It's very moving, Tom. I think it's very moving. Yeah, it is. Well, that's what I found about Dickens is that when I was young and I read him, I was, you know, youthful and cynical and contemptuous of his sentimentality. Whereas now, in middle age, I just sob. Yeah, no, I agree with you. I've become far more attuned to it i think um i think it's almost too tempting to sort of poke fun at dickens well so last last last christmas in the depths of the
愿上帝保佑我们所有人，每一个人。愿上帝保佑我们每一个人，是的。这非常感人，汤姆。我觉得非常感人。是的，确实如此。嗯，这就是我对狄更斯的发现，那就是当我年轻读他的作品时，我是，你知道的，年少轻狂、愤世嫉俗，对他的多愁善感不屑一顾。而现在，步入中年，我只有啜泣。是的，不，我同意你的看法。我觉得我已经变得更加能够理解它了，嗯，我觉得去取笑狄更斯简直太诱人了。好吧，所以上一个——上一个圣诞节，在
lockdown i read quite a lot of dickens and i read um uh tale of two cities which i hadn't read since school right when i really hadn't enjoyed it that's terribly moving at the end it's so good and i was i was literally in tears at the end yeah i read the children's version of that's terribly moving at the end it's so good and i was i was literally in tears at the end yeah i read the children's version of that's my son and it was a bit like a boyish tear it was a bit like when no he was completely different but it was a bit like when i read the lion the witch and the wardrobe there were bits where i kind of choked up i was like what's wrong with you why can't you carry on reading no anyway back so back to uh back to to scrooge so he's very moved by this um very worried about tiny tim you know is tiny tim going
封城的深渊中，我读了相当多的狄更斯，我读了——嗯——《双城记》，自从上学以来我就没读过了，对，当时我真的很不喜欢它，结尾感人至极，太棒了，结尾时我真的泪流满面，是的，我读了儿童版的，结尾感人至极，太棒了，结尾时我真的泪流满面，是的，我读了儿童版的，那是我儿子读的，那有点像一种男孩式的眼泪，有点像当——不，他完全不同，但有点像当我读《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》时，有些地方我哽咽了，我当时想，你怎么了，你为什么读不下去了，不，不管怎样，回到——所以回到——嗯，回到——斯克鲁奇，所以他对此非常感动，嗯，非常担心小蒂姆，你知道，小蒂姆会
to be all right yes um and then the ghost of christmas present vanishes and we we get the appearance of the most terrifying ghost of all who is the ghost of christmas to come so he's sort of a jk rowling star dementor isn't he or a nazgul or a nazgul or i suppose i mean he's he's the grim reaper isn't he's a figure of utter dread so he's he's black cloaked you can't see his face he never talks yeah he only never talks only shows but i think that we should um we we should talk about the third ghost. Yes. Not here. Oh.
没事的，对吧，嗯——然后圣诞幽灵消失了，我们——我们迎来了最可怕的幽灵，也就是未来圣诞幽灵，所以他有点像J·K·罗琳笔下的摄魂怪，不是吗？或者一个戒灵，或者一个戒灵，或者我想说，他——他就是死神，对吧？他是一个令人极度恐惧的人物，所以他——他穿着黑斗篷，你看不到他的脸，他从不说话，对，他从来不说话，只会展示，但我认为我们应该——我们——我们应该谈谈第三个幽灵。是的。不在这里。哦。
But in a graveyard, which is where the ghost ends up taking Scrooge. Not least because there's a lot of banging and drilling in the background, which the listeners may well have heard. So let's head to our next destination on our Christmas Carol pilgrimage. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
而是在墓地里，幽灵最终把斯克鲁奇带到了那里。不仅因为背景里有很多敲打和钻孔的声音，听众们可能已经听到了。所以让我们前往我们圣诞颂歌朝圣之旅的下一个目的地。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论的每周固定节目，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
一抹娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番剧并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
So, Tom, where are we now? Okay, we have come to St. Peter upon Cornhill, which, as the name suggests, we're still in Cornhill um and this church actually i mean quite aside from dickens is a very interesting church you you could walk along cornhill and barely notice it well it's because it's in one of the it's warren of this maze of courts but if you yeah so if you come off cornhill uh you know you you see the the graveyard um and you see the back of the church and this reputedly is the oldest church in britain amazingly supposedly founded by that well-known historical figure king lucius right in the second century uh ad yeah i don't remember him in there he's he's mentioned by bead um as as being you know a very early christian who founded this church so that probably do the romans know of him
那么，汤姆，我们现在在哪里？好的，我们来到了康希尔圣彼得教堂，顾名思义，我们仍然在康希尔，嗯，这座教堂实际上——除了狄更斯之外，是一座非常有趣的教堂，你沿着康希尔走过去，可能根本不会注意到它。好吧，这是因为它在那些——在这个庭院迷宫的深处，但如果你——是的，如果你从康希尔拐出来，你知道，你会看到墓地，你会看到教堂的背面，据传说，这是英国最古老的教堂，令人惊叹的是，据说是由那个著名的历史人物鲁修斯国王在公元二世纪建立的，是的，我不记得他在里面出现过，他被比德提及，说他是一个很早的基督徒，建立了这座教堂，所以罗马人可能知道他吗？
unlikely unlikely but it's mentioned by john stowe who's the great um the the great tudor writer about london at the end of the 16th century um and he cites a tablet um claiming that king lucius had founded this church it was obviously destroyed in the great fire rebuilt by wren um the weather vane has a key in the shape of saint peter's, letting people into heaven. But, I mean, that's all by the by. The reason why I've brought you here is that it is probably in this graveyard that the final climactic scene in Scrooge's experience with the three ghosts occurs. So, where the ghost of Christmas past.
不太可能，不太可能，但约翰·斯托提到了他，他是16世纪末关于伦敦的伟大的都铎时期作家，嗯，他引用了一块牌匾，声称鲁修斯国王建立了这座教堂，它显然在大火中被毁，由雷恩重建，风向标上有一把圣彼得钥匙形状的钥匙，通往天堂。但是，嗯，那都是题外话。我带你来这里的原因是，正是在这个墓地里，斯克鲁奇经历三个幽灵的最后高潮场景可能就发生在这里。所以，过去圣诞幽灵。
The ghost of Christmas future. Oh, sorry. Yes, ghost of Christmas future. Oh, sorry. Yes. Ghost Christmas future. And the ghost shows what is likely to come. And he shows Scrooge a kind of rag and bone man in a squalid area of London, parceling up the goods of an obviously deceased man. Nobody cares for them. Nobody wants them. They're just being dispelled. Then he takes Scrooge to the city and various bankers and financial luminaries that scrooge knows are walking a lot through the streets talking about someone who's died in a tone of absolute kind of they don't care they only want
未来圣诞幽灵。哦，抱歉。是的，未来圣诞幽灵。哦，抱歉。是的。未来圣诞幽灵。幽灵展示了可能会发生的事情。他向斯克鲁奇展示了伦敦一个肮脏地区的一个收买破烂的人，正在打包一个明显已经去世的人的物品。没有人关心他们。没有人想要他们。他们只是被驱逐了。然后他把斯克鲁奇带到城市里，斯克鲁奇认识的各种银行家和金融界知名人士在街头走来走去，谈论着一个死去的人，语气绝对是——他们不在乎，他们只想
to go to the if there's going to be a free lunch exactly yes yes nobody cares nobody cares and that and all the time scrooge is saying who is this person i mean he's either being yeah he doesn't want to face up to the possibility of who it might be then they go And all the time Scrooge is saying, who is this person? I mean, he's either being very obtuse. He doesn't want to face up to the possibility of who it might be. But then they go back to Camden, don't they? They go to Camden. Yeah. And they go to the Cratchits' house.
去吃——如果有免费午餐的话，确实，是的，是的，没有人关心，没有人关心，而斯克鲁奇一直在说，这个人是谁？我的意思是，他要么是——是的，他不想正视这可能是谁的可能性。然后他们去——而斯克鲁奇一直在问，这个人是谁？我的意思是，他要么是在装糊涂。他不想去面对这可能是谁的可能性。但随后他们回到了卡姆登，不是吗？他们去了卡姆登。是的。他们去了克拉奇特家。
Oh, it's a terrible scene. Is Tiny Tim still there? No, Tiny Tim is dead. Bob has just visited the grave, hasn't he? And he says it's very green and you'd like it. And they all talk about how they'll remember Tiny Tim and what a lovely fellow he was. And they'll behave in a more Christian way now
哦，这是一个可怕的场景。小蒂姆还在那里吗？不，小蒂姆死了。鲍勃刚去过墓地，不是吗？他说那里非常绿，你会喜欢的。他们都在谈论他们将如何记住小蒂姆，他是一个多么可爱的人。他们现在会表现得更有基督徒风范
when they think of Tiny Tim. And the crutches are by the fire. It's very moving. Very, very moving. Well, you know, if you're 17, you laugh at this. Or if you're Oscar Wilde. But if you're a bit older. Yeah.
当他们想起小蒂姆的时候。拐杖就放在壁炉边。非常感人。非常，非常感人。好吧，你知道，如果你17岁，你会嘲笑这个。或者如果你是王尔德。但如果你稍微年长一点。是的。
With a child of your own. Yes, you do find it moving. Yes, absolutely. And then? And then? Well, then they reach an iron gate and i shall read from the book it says he paused to look around before entering a churchyard here then the wretched man whose name he had now to learn lay underneath the ground it was a worthy
带着你自己的孩子。是的，你会觉得很感人。是的，绝对如此。然后呢？然后呢？嗯，然后他们来到了一扇铁门前，我从书中读到：“他停下来四处张望，然后才走进教堂墓地。在这里，这个可怜的人——他现在必须知道他的名字——就躺在地下。这是一个值得纪念的
place walled in by houses as as it is now walled in by houses, overrun by grass and weeds, which it isn't, but overrun by grass and weeds, the growth of vegetation's death, not life, choked up with too much burying, fat with repleted appetite, a worthy place.
地方，四周环绕着房子——正如现在四周环绕着房子一样，杂草丛生，其实并没有，但杂草丛生，植被生长的不是生命而是死亡，因埋葬太多而窒息，饱食着过量的欲望，一个值得纪念的地方。”
The spirit leads Scrooge into this graveyard and he points towards a grave. Tell us what's written on the grave well following the finger he read upon the stone of the neglected grave his own name and dickens puts it in capital letters ebenezer scrooge do you know where ebenezer scrooge the name come came from no uh apparently dickens had visited a grave in edinburgh i think by a man called ebenezer scroggie who turned out was a very jovial man a great philanderer man with an eye for the ladies and a kind of laugh a minute party goer but i'm glad you didn't call him scroogie no
精灵引领斯克鲁奇走进这片墓地，他指向一座坟墓。告诉我们墓碑上写着什么。嗯，顺着手指，他在那座被忽视的坟墓的石头上读到了他自己的名字，狄更斯用大写字母写着：埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇。你知道埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇这个名字是从哪里来的吗？不。嗯，显然狄更斯在爱丁堡参观过一座坟墓，我想是一个叫埃比尼泽·斯克罗吉的人，结果发现他是一个非常快活的人，一个风流成性的人，对女性很有眼光，是一个喜欢聚会、每分钟都充满欢笑的人，但我很高兴你没叫他“斯克罗吉”。不。
i wouldn't work at all scroogie wouldn't work anyway so so, so Scrooge wakes up from this, finds that it's all been a dream and that it's all happened over the course of Christmas morning. Yes. And he calls out to a passing boy, you know, what morn is it? And the boy says, it's Christmas morning. And Scrooge tells him to go and buy a turkey.
这行不通，“斯克罗吉”根本行不通。不管怎样，所以——所以，斯克鲁奇从梦中醒来，发现这一切都只是一场梦，而且这一切都发生在圣诞节的早晨。是的。他向路过的一个男孩喊道，你知道，现在是什么早晨？男孩说，今天是圣诞节早晨。斯克鲁奇让他去买一只火鸡。
And the boy rushes off to Leadenhall Market market which is just around the corner where we're going to head now a delightful boy excellent boy the first christmas i spent in london i came to leadenhall market and i bought a goose a goose not a turkey no i bought a goose because i thought it was more decency well it is more like bob cratchit was a bit disappointed to have a turkey at the end rather than a goose and i carried it the whole way back to our little Bob Cratchit type flat and it was a brilliantly Dickensian experience now so Dickensian Christmases Tom there's light and shade in them yeah and let's bring in a bit of the shade because you have had an experience haven't you with a turkey yes uh which always i'm sorry
男孩冲向了利登霍尔市场——就在我们现在要去的拐角处——一个令人愉快的男孩，出色的男孩。我在伦敦度过的第一个圣诞节，我来到了利登霍尔市场，我买了一只鹅，一只鹅，不是火鸡。不，我买了一只鹅，因为我觉得它更体面。好吧，它确实更像——鲍勃·克拉奇特最后买到火鸡而不是鹅会有点失望——我把它一路背回了我们那间小小的鲍勃·克拉奇特式的公寓，那是一次非常具有狄更斯风格的经历。那么，狄更斯式的圣诞节，汤姆，其中有光明也有阴暗，对吧？让我们引入一点阴暗，因为你确实有过一次经历，对吧？关于火鸡。是的，呃——我总是很遗憾地
to say it was slightly amuses me did you not once buy a turkey and have it stolen out to the back of your car yes i did christmas on christmas eve yeah it was on christmas eve um because i didn't have room and we had a very small fridge uh and this was a kind of um scrooge type turkey of an enormous size and we uh yeah we so so we you know we didn't want it to we wanted to keep it cold so we kept it in the um in the in the boot of the car and some some wanker are you allowed to say that in the christmas podcast i think so some wanker broke into the car and uh nicked it so we we just had all the trimmings it was very nice it was the best christmas ever oh yeah god bless us everyone tiny tom yeah tom we're in a very we're in a splendid location now so tell us where we are so we are now in leadenhall market um and there's been um
说，这稍微有点娱乐到我。你是不是曾买过一只火鸡，结果它在你的车后备箱被人偷了？是的，我买过。圣诞节前夜。是的，那是在圣诞前夜，嗯，因为我没有空间，我们有一个非常小的冰箱，而这是一只——呃——斯克鲁奇式的大得惊人的火鸡，我们——是的，所以——所以，你知道，我们不想让它——我们想保持低温，所以我们把它放在了——嗯——车的后备箱里。然后某个混蛋——你能在圣诞播客里说这个吗？我想可以——某个混蛋砸碎了车窗，把它给偷了。所以我们只有所有的配菜。这非常棒。这是有史以来最好的圣诞节。哦，是的。愿上帝保佑我们每一个人，小汤姆。是的，汤姆，我们现在在一个非常——一个极好的地方。所以告诉我们我们在哪里。所以我们现在在利登霍尔市场，嗯，这里
a market here from the 14th century it's actually on the site of the roman basilica and there's the only chunk of the roman basilica is to be found in the barber shop that is over there it's in the basement um and it's a legal requirement i think of the planning but um if you want to go and see this chunk of the basilica you have to have your haircut no they have to let you in oh really they have to let you in so you go down and see it but this this particular incarnation was was built in 1881 and it's very very victorian i mean it's so this isn't the one that uh that scrooge would have named but it still gives a very victorian it's a bit more late victorian isn't it there are reeds everywhere there's kind of
从14世纪起就有一个市场。它实际上位于罗马大教堂的遗址上，罗马大教堂唯一的一块残存部分可以在那边的理发店里找到。它在地下室里，嗯，这好像是规划部门的一项法律要求，但是，嗯，如果你想去看这块大教堂的残存部分，你必须去理发。不，他们必须让你进去。哦，真的吗？他们必须让你进去。所以你下去看它。但这个特定的版本建于1881年，非常非常维多利亚风格。我的意思是，所以这不是斯克鲁奇会点的那座，但它仍然给人一种非常维多利亚——它更像晚期维多利亚风格，对吧？到处都是芦苇，有各种
christmas trees it's all very very very festive and this is yeah and so this is where dickens buys his uh sorry dickens that's a significant slip uh scrooge buys this enormous turkey yeah he takes it to bob cratchit so this is interesting doesn't it it gets screwed everybody thinks that scrooge pitches up at the cratchit's house and comes down but he doesn't he goes to fred's house yeah he does astonishes everybody by pitching up at fred's yeah so michael kane at the end of the muppets he he goes to both he does both yeah but that's not right yeah he should not go to visit Miss Biggie because the twist is the next morning when Bob Cratchit comes in late because he's had such a great time what with all his
圣诞树，到处都非常非常有节日气氛。这就是——所以这就是狄更斯买他的——抱歉，狄更斯——这是一个明显的口误——斯克鲁奇买这只巨大的火鸡的地方。是的，他把它带给鲍勃·克拉奇特。所以这很有趣，不是吗？每个人都以为斯克鲁奇气势汹汹地来到克拉奇特家，不请自来。但其实他没有，他去了弗雷德的家。是的，他确实去了。他通过不请自来地出现在弗雷德家震惊了所有人。是的，所以在《布偶圣诞颂歌》的结尾，迈克尔·凯恩他两边都去了，他两边都去了。是的。但那是不对的。是的，他不应该去拜访猪小姐，因为转折发生在第二天早上，鲍勃·克拉奇特迟到了，因为他玩得太开心了，有那么多
punch and everything yeah and Scrooge pretends to be the miserable old skin that he'd always been and he says Bob Cratchit I'm going to give you a raise. Yes, exactly. And it's non-stop polarity and Scrooge then basically becomes a second father to Tiny Tim who doesn't die
潘趣酒之类的一切。是的。而斯克鲁奇假装成他一贯的那种痛苦的老吝啬鬼，他说：“鲍勃·克拉奇特，我要给你加薪。”是的，完全正确。这是不间断的反转，斯克鲁奇随后基本上成了小蒂姆的第二个父亲，小蒂姆没有死。
and they all, you know, always festive and well. Now here's an interesting thing about Tiny Tim not dying. It was only added at a very late stage in the printing presses.
他们所有人都，你知道，永远充满节日气氛，身体健康。现在这里有一件关于小蒂姆没有死趣事。这只是在印刷厂的后期阶段才被添加进去的。
So originally, they didn't say that explicitly, because it's quite a sentimental touch. Tiny Tim, who did not in capitals die. I mean, that's a bit of fan service, I think, as they would call it now, isn't it? Yeah. And Scrooge, he became as good a friend, as good a master, and as good a man as the good old city knew, or any other good old city, town, or borough in the good old world.
所以最初，他们并没有明确说出来，因为这是一种相当感人的笔触。“小蒂姆，他没有死”——用了大写字母。我的意思是，正如他们现在所说的那样，这有点像是粉丝福利，不是吗？是的。而斯克鲁奇，他成了一个像那个美好老城市所知道的、或这个美好老世界上任何其他美好老城市、城镇或自治市镇所知道的那么好的朋友、那么好的主人和那么好的人。
Yes. Now let's talk a bit about just a bit about the meaning of A Christmas Carol, because Tony, our producer, who is this sort of glowering shadow throughout our recording. Yes. Pointing on it, taking off his flat cap and looking disapproving at various points yes pointing out that it it's made by a hat maker uh by appointment to the duke of edinburgh while simultaneously grumbling about trade unions so very very exactly very split very much in a kind of Dickensian way yeah that's very much the uh the modern labor party some might say um anyway he has pointed out quite rightly that in some ways a christ A Christmas Carol is a very conservative book. Because basically, the argument of
是的。现在让我们来谈谈——仅谈谈《圣诞颂歌》的意义，因为托尼，我们的制作人，他就像是我们录音过程中一直投射着阴影的存在。是的。指指点点，摘下扁帽，在各个节点表现出不赞成。是的，指出它是——由一家帽子制造商制造的——由爱丁堡公爵任命——同时又在抱怨工会。所以非常非常——非常分裂，非常具有狄更斯式的风格。是的，这非常符合现代工党的作风，有些人可能会这么说。无论如何，他非常正确地指出，在某些方面，《圣诞颂歌》是一个非常保守的书。因为基本上，《圣诞颂歌》的论点是
A Christmas Carol is there are tremendous, I mean, the context of these tremendous inequalities, poor and rich living cheap by jowl, but sort of not meeting. But the answer to this is individual philanthropy. We'll buy everyone a turkey. And there were people who literally did that. So there was,
《圣诞颂歌》展现了巨大的——我的意思是，其背景是巨大的不平等，穷人和富人紧密相邻地生活，但某种程度上却没有交集。但解决这个问题的办法是个人慈善事业。我们会给每个人买一只火鸡。确实有人字面意义上这么做了。所以，
I think there was someone in a factory in owner in boston who read it and was he gave everyone the day off and bought them all turkeys that's right yes um and i think somebody there was a comment in the times or something to the to the effect of ever since it's been published people are just rushing around buying turkeys for people um so that is essentially dickens's solution to to want individual self-improvement and philanthropy and so on which now people would perceive as in some ways quite a that's right message i would say well so um lenin a few years after the russian revolution went to a staging of one of dickens's christmas Christmas stories and was so appalled by its borderline morality that he walked out midway through.
我想波士顿有一家工厂的老板读了这本书，他给每个人放了一天假，给他们每人都买了火鸡。没错，是的。嗯，我想《泰晤士报》或其他地方曾发表过一条评论，大意是自从这本书出版以来，人们就一直在争相为别人买火鸡。所以这基本上就是狄更斯对匮乏的解决方案——个人的自我完善和慈善事业等等，现在人们在某些方面会认为这是一个相当——那是对的，我想说的是，好吧，所以——列宁在俄国革命几年后，去观看了一场狄更斯的圣诞故事的改编戏剧，对其游走于边缘的道德观感到如此震惊，以至于他在中途退场了。
Lenin walked out of a production of Dickens. Yeah. That's a play in itself, isn't it? Yeah, it's brilliant, isn't it? Yeah, kind of Orlando Annucci doing something with that. Yes. But I suppose that's part of the fascination with Dickens. Dickens is simultaneously appalled by the kind of costs
列宁看狄更斯的戏看到一半中途退场了。是的。这本身就是一出戏，不是吗？是的，太棒了，不是吗？是的，有点像阿曼多·伊安努奇会拿来做点什么的那种感觉。是的。但我想这也是狄更斯的魅力所在。狄更斯一方面对维多利亚时代进步的代价等感到震惊。
of Victorian progress and so on. with dickens the dickens is simultaneously appalled by the by the kind of costs of you know victorian progress and so on and yet he's he's a moralist isn't he's a concern as many moralists are he tends to be quite conservative because he brings everything back to the the the virtue or vice of the individual rather than of society at large he i mean he feels horror at the institutionalization of the kind of inequalities in victorian britain so scrooge is notorious you know are there not workhouses yes are there not prisons yeah uh you know why don't people die to to lower the surplus population so anti-malthus isn't it anti-malthus political economists uh again? Anti-Malthus, political economists. Again, it's the ledger book. It's the idea of reducing people to statistics, to figures in an accountancy book.
对于狄更斯来说，狄更斯一方面对维多利亚时代进步的代价等等感到震惊，然而他却是一个道德家，不是吗？正如许多道德家一样，他往往相当保守，因为他把一切都归结为个人的美德或恶习，而不是整个社会的。他——我的意思是，他对维多利亚时代英国那种不平等的制度化感到恐惧——所以斯克鲁奇是出了名的，你知道，“难道没有工场手工业吗？是的。难道没有监狱吗？是的。你知道，为什么人们不死掉以减少过剩人口呢？”所以反马尔萨斯主义，对吧？反马尔萨斯主义政治经济学家，又来了。反马尔萨斯主义政治经济学家。再次强调，这是账本。这是把人贬低为统计数据、会计账簿上的数字的想法。
That fills him with horror. And the counterpoint to that is, yeah, is kind of personal joy, I guess, and personal benignity. The buying of turkeys for people. Well, that's arguably why One Reason Why Christmas Carol is so successful and so popular. I mean, it was written for a very middle-class audience, for a literate middle-class audience. And that's probably the audience that it still reaches because it's not a politically radical book in a troubling way.
这让他感到恐惧。与之相对的是，是的，某种程度上是个人快乐，我想，还有个人的仁慈。为人们买火鸡。好吧，这可以说是《圣诞颂歌》如此成功、如此受欢迎的原因之一。我的意思是，它是为非常中产阶级的观众写的，为识字的中产阶级观众写的。这可能仍然是它所触及的观众，因为它不是一本以令人不安的方式具有政治激进色彩的书。
It's a book that says, give a little bit more to charity at christmas and i think that's why people that's why that's how we say affluent respectable well-off people love it because it makes you feel it doesn't make scrooge feel bad about being rich but i think it's also i mean as we said the beginning it's although it it does have this kind of quite strong political seedbed it it also has a kind of it has the quality of fairy tale of folk tale almost of myth or of legend and that makes i mean i'm sure that's one of the reasons why it must rank as the most adapted story certainly in english is that you can do almost anything with
这是一本告诉你“在圣诞节多做点慈善”的书，我想这就是为什么人们——这就是为什么我们这些富裕、体面、生活优渥的人喜欢它，因为它让你感觉——它不会让斯克鲁奇因为富有而感到糟糕。但我也认为——正如我们开始时所说的那样——尽管它确实有这样一种相当强烈的政治根基，但它也具有一种童话、民间传说、甚至神话或传说的特质。这使得——我确信这也是它必定成为英语世界中被改编次数最多的故事的原因之一，因为你可以用它做任何事。
it so you can you know obviously when i said that we were doing this show lots of people wrote and said you must mention the muppets as the best and we have given i think lots of lots of airtime to the muppets but also you know you've had scrooge mcduck the you know the disney version of it scrooge bill murray screw yes so so it's come in many many shapes and forms and i think that that that reflects the fact that it is infinitely malleable and infinitely parodable infinitely adaptable and as we said in our christmas podcast that we did at this time last year christmas is in many ways dickens's and the victorians creation isn't it yeah the turkey the goose the trimmings the carols the cards the tree these things date from dickens's lifetime um So we're still kind of, you know,
所以你可以——你知道，显然当我提到我们在做这个节目时，很多人写信说你一定要提《布偶圣诞颂歌》是最好的，而我们已经为《布偶圣诞颂歌》提供了很多节目时间，但除此之外，你知道，你还有 Scrooge McDuck，你知道的，迪士尼版本的斯克鲁奇，比尔·默瑞的斯克鲁奇，是的——所以它以非常非常多的形状和形式出现，我认为这反映了这样一个事实，即它是无限可塑的，无限可戏仿的，无限可改编的，正如我们在去年这个时候做的圣诞播客中所说的那样，圣诞节在很大程度上是狄更斯和维多利亚时代人创造的，不是吗？是的。火鸡、鹅、配菜、颂歌、卡片、树，这些东西都起源于狄更斯的一生，
we are almost self-consciously re-enacting a Victorian Christmas every time we celebrate Christmas. And I think, Dominic, that that is the perfect note on which to end. You look like you're gearing up for a reading, Tom, are you? No, I'm going to say happy Christmas to everyone. Festive best wishes. And God bless us. god bless us god bless us everyone everyone from me and from tiny tom happy christmas happy christmas thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
所以我们基本上仍然在，你知道，每当我们庆祝圣诞节时，我们几乎都在自觉地重演一个维多利亚时期的圣诞节。我想，多米尼克，这正是结束本期节目的完美音符。汤姆，你看上去好像在准备朗读什么，是吗？不，我要向每个人祝圣诞快乐。致以节日的最佳祝愿。愿上帝保佑我们。愿上帝保佑我们。愿上帝保佑我们每一个人。每一个人，从我和小汤姆这里，圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家番剧、提前收听、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。